every single day we take the uh we take
the uh
uh dan patrick show audience gladly
put it on our backs carry it yep
hand it off to brother from another
every day right here on peacock
nbc sports on peacock i've not spoken to
this gentleman in quite some time so i'm
pleased to have uh here we had
michael holly on last week so to be fair
and balanced
michael smith joins us from brother from
another we take you to his program in
about 15 minutes time right here on the
show
how are you michael how you been good
fair and balanced kind of like equal
time
well look i don't want you to be upset
or
jealous um you know what i'm saying god
no you know i mean i i
i use the word jealous because it makes
me and this show look better
so that's why i wanted to say that how
do you know
listen i mean i i just don't want to
ruin the end of your show you started
off by saying how you guys hand it off
to us
i i don't know if you heard me i was
like how's that working out i mean you
guys carry dan's audience
uh hopefully all the way to you you know
and dan carries it
dan dan carries a lot every single day i
mean if you've seen the dan patrick show
for quite some time i mean
you hear what mclovin comes up out of
his skull all the
time and then he's got a he hands it off
to us and we hand it off to you which is
a
fantastic i hope we're holding it is all
i'm saying i'm sure you are
i have no eye dropping i hope we're not
dropping the baton well i don't i
haven't looked into the
research on that front if i'm not
mistaken you are on the air in 14
minutes correct
the lights will go on and the
microphones will work right that's all
you need
that's all you need to do so far so good
there you go um do you remember how long
you've been doing this
uh the owners the everyday the everyday
uh all-day everyday thing six years six
years now
do you remember uh you remember show 44
um not specifically i just mean do you
remember the early days of the show
oh my gosh uh i wear these scars every
day
emotionally oh yeah you're right man
it's been a while to be talked i need a
i need to pick me up oh gee
you know what do you need what do you
need just just some uh
you know i was on the i was all i was
out the game for a minute on the
sideline for
a stretch there right i'm still getting
my still get my legs underneath me
um all right still getting my routine my
rhythm
okay doesn't quite feel right man like
obviously the relationship in the
history and the chemistry michael holly
goes 20 years
been 20 years in the making but you know
wrong wasn't built in a day i know
michael that's just having these days
man where sometimes i'm like damn you
know like
can't i can't get this right like even
going into today you mentioned i'm on
there in 12 minutes yes sir
and my head all over the place right now
well i mean so let me let me let
what are you talking about at the top of
your show let's let's do a little
preview what are you guys uh having
uh we're talking about this rocket's
drama what is yes now here's
let's get into this okay let's get into
this here
what's the phrase that loge and tim
mcmahon use yes this is
as you know as you know michael uh
having done this for a very long time
um that people who uh trade in
information
um have to sometimes infuse their
language with
uh a hedge or two because you know
nothing's concrete
nothing's given so teams make plans
uh players are expected to that sort of
stuff yeah
yeah this is this is in the all-time
hall of fame
uh version of that this was yesterday
about westbrook and hardin
where they said that they had not
requested a trade at this point but yet
what was the phrase that was used chris
plausible eventual possibility that was
it wasn't that great
incredible that's like the triple lindy
right there and now here we have i never
heard that one before
it looks like russell's done it right
that's what it looks like
yeah um what do you think and if i'm the
rockets i'm grateful for it
uh because that team's not going
anywhere it's been a fun run
they've tried it and tried it and tried
it various iterations whether it was
dwight howard
whether it was chris paul whether it was
a cup of coffee with carmelo anthony
and now russell westbrook good run uh
but
but the band's broken up and if you got
two guys or even one of those guys
coming to you looking for a way out i'm
obliging them
because you know they're not contending
for a championship they're spinning
their wheels
and now come to find out it's been
dysfunctional on top of all of that
the issue is going to be you know what
can you get for russell westbrook and
that albatross of a contract
if somebody like the knicks or the
hornets want to give you
anything uh i'm i'm i'm jumping at that
opportunity and frankly i'm asking
hardin if he's sure he wants to stick it
out you know because i'm i'm open to
trading harden
the the talk about words that kind of
jump out the idea them being protective
of hardin and westbrook like why
protective of winning 44 games
protective of losing in the second round
it's like they want to break up break it
up blow it up tear it all down that's
where i'm at if i'm houston now
if you're houston you know uh maury
covets
harden who would you from the sixers ask
back
who would you take back let's just keep
let's just play this out
if i were the rockets and i was talking
to sixes who were correct correct
that you know i want to be that it
starts with embiid
i don't think there's i don't think
that's the contest for me in terms of
the better player between him and
simmons it starts with mv but if they
won't if they won't trade one of their
stars and you're just trying to and
that's the thing if you're trying to
unload harden then you want as many pics
as you can get out of the sixers
and as many of their young pieces as
they'll give you but if you're looking
star for star which i doubt the sixers
would be interested in right
that i that i would pick and be but my
thing is
with houston is like you're not going to
get
likely equal value for james harden
you're also not in a position
with the lack of assets that they have
given what they've done to try to build
a team around him
you're not a position to improve your
team so you may have to take less for
houston
for harden if you're houston under the
guise of
building your future you know they won
44 games last year you know what else
won 44 games last year
the thunder like take a page out of sam
presley's book
and say you know what give me give me
all your picks for my star
and granted they got chris paul back in
in the westbrook trade but
sam presley seems to have figured out
how to keep this thing moving
and not compromise his future if nothing
else set himself up for the long run
while still being competitive so
take a page out of that book no doubt
man no question about it and you have to
sit here and think that when durant and
the thunder were up 3-1
um in that western conference finals
that do you think that'll be the high
water mark of russell westbrook's career
would you think that right probably
probably right uh because i mean if you
talk about the hornets or the knicks
he he may go back to averaging a triple
double but uh
i don't anticipate a scenario in which
he's on a contending team because if you
read the article it sounds like he wants
his own team
or he wants to be the one that's uh
implementing and establishing the
culture he wants to be the leader on and
off the court of the team
i guess this is the last one then this
is the last one for you because i want
to make sure
you're in your chair on time oh i'm
already in a chair
i'm in my home studio i'm in the chair i
got my coffee i'm straight do you think
jordan would take russell westbrook
i do i do to unload uh contracts
like uh you know biambo or rozier and
uh maybe get a uh you know some other
uh assets back or something i don't i
don't know that he'd do it and give up a
high draft pick in the process to get
him but there's also the jordan brand
relationship too there too
as well so i think you i think he might
i think he's enamored with russell
westbrook enough
uh to trade some pieces for him
but before before i do go man i just
want some i just want some og advice man
i want some
look i've done i've done this a long
time yes but every show is different
every every
part it is it is and let me just if
you're asking i'll tell it okay and
again i know you got three minutes to go
what you and jamelle did
was great okay
because you did seriously because what
you and jamelle did
was you it was you it wasn't what some
version of what you thought it should be
it was the two of you doing what the two
of you wanted to do
period end of story and because it
didn't if you will
work out it doesn't mean that what
you're doing right now isn't worth
a damn and anything in the beginning
never feels like it does
the day after the day after the day
after this what you've got going on here
i'm sorry um uh you asked i'm going to
tell you it this is what i would tell
you off the air too what we've got
cooking right here with florio
into dan and to me into you into florio
and what's going to be built
this is the place to be it's a streamer
it's a streamer it's got nbc sports
behind it
they like it i enjoy it dan enjoys it
you've got your a couple of hours with
michael holly to build on
this is exactly the future this is
exactly the place to be
and the conversation we just had you
bring that with holly
and let's go you know i'm having fun i
really am having fun
and i uh i'm glad to be a part of the
team it's just certain days man i even
haven't done this for 20 years there's
still just certain days where i just
i get i tend to get in my own head
sometimes and i'm like damn you know is
this
is this the right rundown are we doing
the right topics are we are we executing
this the right way
and again we're only you know yeah
you're 44 shows and you're you're
your head is the right place to be
michael because your head is your own
and you've got your unique take on
things and you and holly have a unique
relationship and just let it grow
enjoy it yeah enjoy it totally enjoy it
and
you know and and have have more takes
like this one and keep talking about the
stuff that i do
uh and that then then you're great
i was like you know what i'm saying
y'all
michael like stuff like that you know
actually you know what you know to take
it true lamar jackson's
all right here you go you're
[Music]
thanks for the content oh have a great
show
we'll we'll be out there now thanks to
you i feel much better
have a blast that's uh michael smith
that's michael smith
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here